pour moi le le monde il vit en deux il y
a les bons et les cons
bonsoir
alors donc vous étiez au stade vous
expliquer comment ça s'est passé tout le
monde s'explique
alors ça a commencé par des sifflements
lors de la Marseillaise comment ça s'est
passé ben écoutez ça a commencé au début
c'était sympa
et après je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mais moi j'ai pas compris
ils ont sifflé la Marseillaise donc j'ai
pas trouvé ça terrible du tout j'étais
même choqué
et
j'avais pas les mots sur place en fait
j'étais vraiment je m'attendais pas du
tout à ça j'attendais un match de paix
un peu de tolérance de mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a une chose c'est qu'on peut pas
régler
l'histoire avec un match de foot qui
dure 90 minutes et on a tellement mis de
pression là dessus que mais bon c'est
pas pour ça c'est pas exclusables du
tout sur ce je trouve ça inadmissible
que des Français sifflent La
Marseillaise n'importe quel hymne mais
les jeunes qui sont descendus sur le
terrain ils sont français ouais c'est
des Français pourquoi il descendent avec
un drapeau algérien ben vous savez quand
c'est pour ça que je vais vous répondre
sur le parcours que j'ai fait j'ai écrit
ça dans mon livre c'est que toute mon
enfance mes parents quand ils sont venus
ici c'était un passage pour eux c'était
pas éternel pour tout le temps et dans
ce passage c'était pas chez eux ici donc
dans l'éducation on m'a éduqué en me
disant Jamel tu es un Algérien tu es pas
français
toute ma vie ça a été ça enfin jusqu'à
16 ans et juste des clics lorsque je la
chance je dis bien j'ai eu la chance de
monter à Paris parce que je suis
originaire de Lyon dans les quartiers où
on nous a mis contre nous on va dire
qu'entre français d'origine étrangère et
c'est quand j'ai eu la chance de monter
à 16 ans je me suis dit j'ai eu cela où
j'ai compris qu'en fait que je devais
être français que je devais être fier
d'être français et parce que j'ai ramené
énormément de médailles pour la France
et que j'étais fier de ce pays et puis
voilà ces jeunes qui sont venus sur le
terrain samedi et qui ont sifflait la
Marseillaise et moi aussi j'ai comme
Jamel Bouras évidemment c'est
regrettable et choquant à bien des
égards en même temps je suis sûr que
beaucoup d'entre eux sont les mêmes qui
a deux ou trois ans défilé avec des
drapeaux français
Zidane champion du monde et cette France
black Bamber qui avait gagné mais
surtout ces mots là qui font mal aussi
alors tu vois c'est tous ces mots-là
pendant toute mon excusez-moi de vous
couper hein mais lorsque quand j'ai
réussi je me suis dit ça y est je ramène
des bottes j'étais dans le monde entier
avec le drapeau français qui m'entend
que j'étais fier j'avais les larmes aux
yeux tu vois j'étais vraiment content et
quand tu quand je revenais avec ma
médaille alors en tant que beurre
comment ça va
donner je suis un Français qu'est-ce que
c'est ces mots là-dedans je ne connais
pas moi je connais le bord que je mets
le matin sur mes tartines mais ce bord
là je comprends pas alors est-ce que
vous sentez bien intégré je suis
intégration de quoi je suis moi je
défends les valeurs républicaines je
suis fier de ces valeurs je suis un
français comme vous c'est quoi et tout
de suite on nous a mis à l'écart on nous
a exclu mais le problème c'est que on va
pas chercher quand l'italien sud de
français d'origine italienne ou le
français d'origine polonaise ou
n'importe quel autre origine quand il y
a son pays d'origine qui vont jouer pour
l'Italie mais nous c'est enfin ces gens
là c'est pareil ils étaient là pour
l'Algérie mais quand la France a gagné
ils étaient ils ont fait la fête j'ai
parlé avec des jeunes qui étaient là-bas
parce que j'étais fou d'orage quand je
suis sorti j'ai essayé même de enfin de
d'intervenir et quand j'ai parlé avec
eux ils m'ont dit tu sais déjà mal nous
on a pas signé on s'en fout de la
Mercedes tout ça non on a signé on a
sifflé pardon en a sifflet la
Marseillaise c'est parce que c'était
David et Goliath et nous on était pour
[Musique]
dans ces histoires là on est toujours
obligé de s'expliquer à cause d'une
centaine de crétins quoi c'est-à-dire
que je pense pas que la majorité des
gens qui étaient là-bas on sifflait la
Marseillaise et il y en a quelques-uns
qui sont rentrés dans le stade mais
c'est tout c'est ça c'est pareil pour
les ce qui se passe en banlieue c'est 10
mecs 20 mecs les terroristes c'est quoi
c'est 100 m 500 mecs dans le monde et
dans le monde on est obligé de changer
notre vie de de changer notre façon de
penser à cause de ces [ __ ]
bah oui
non mais c'est insupportable parce que
la plupart des et en plus c'est mal
tombé parce que c'est un contexte
horrible en ce moment donc il y a des
gens qui font l'amalgame entre arabe et
terroriste et musulman c'est mais de la
part de ses mecs là qui sont rentrés sur
le stade c'est il devrait comprendre il
devrait ceci étant quand même à mon avis
lundi dernier sur France 2 dans
l'émission Mots croisés dans les chabots
on a vu des jeunes dire très simplement
d'ailleurs ok on nous demande de faire 3
minutes de silence pour le World Trade
Center mais pourquoi on fait pas 3
minutes de silence pour les milliers de
morts qui sont dues à l'embargo de
l'Irak au bombardements de l'Irak j'ai
pas vu beaucoup jusqu'à maintenant de de
jeunes d'origine maghrébine
être fondamentalement du côté des
américains ils disent oui c'est vrai
c'est terrible ce qui s'est passé au
World Trade Center mais malgré tout nous
aussi il y a la PA
je suis contre toute terrorisme et je
trouve que les gens qui ont fait ça il
faut les condamner c'est très grave il
faut trouver les coupables faut trouver
le coupable et pas les pas à tuer des
innocents j'espère qu'ils vont trouver
les coupables et les
avoir elle est punir un truc exemplaire
ça c'est clair et net et je me sens pas
du tout en plus avec moi je suis de
confession musulmane mais je crois qu'on
a pas le même le même livre avec
je suis désolé on n'a pas la même
religion le problème il est que enfin
c'est pas le problème je comprends un
peu ce qu'ils veulent dire ces gens là
c'est que
bouche tout à coup on en fait à une
personne super sage presque on va lui
donner le prix Nobel de la paix
de la paix alors que quand même je crois
que dernièrement je passe il y a des
milliers d'exemples à donner mais je
crois qu'il a pas signé les accords de
crypto on peut dire c'est vrai on peut
le dire il a pas signé les accords de
Kyoto il a il a pas fait grand-chose
pour établir la paix en au Moyen-Orient
en disant entre Israël et la Palestine
on peut lui reprocher beaucoup de choses
bien sûr surtout qu'ils ont les moyens
de de surtout la base dans les moyens de
de laisser à Israël à Israël ici avoir
un territoire pour la Palestine et puis
ils vivent ensemble et puis voilà et
puis on arrête avec ses rêves justement
vous vivez en Israël je viens pas faire
de la politique je trouve que c'est un
sujet très très compliqué qui date pas
de 48 ni d'hier ça date de d'Abraham
Ismaël et Isaac et je pense que si c'est
pas trop ici enfin je pense pas que ça
sera ici qu'il faudrait en parler mais
pourquoi pas parce que parce que il
s'agit de la paix dans le monde si on se
mobilise nous pour encourager ceux qui
marchent vers la paix plutôt que de
souffler ce que ceux qui mettent de
l'huile sur ce feu là c'est notre
responsabilité de tous les jours vous
avez dit Israël c'est là la Palestine
c'est là c'est déjà pas vrai donc c'est
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
on va trouver une solution un moment
donné au 10e 11e siècle à l'époque de
l'Andalousie où il vivait ensemble à
merveille tout se passait bien et je
comprends pas pourquoi aujourd'hui on y
arrive pas mais en Algérie il y avait
les trois communautés qui vivaient
ensemble ça se passait très bien mais ça
a toujours existé tu vois ça toujours
existé ça c'est possible mais est-ce que
les ceux qui qu'on le monopole un peu
qui domine le veulent vraiment je sais
pas tu vois
Ellie simplement je pense aux gens là
les terroristes je crois que ça il y a
quand même des siècles de frustrations
peut-être pas mais de frustration de la
part de ces gens-là et pour en dernière
pour en arriver à ça il faut vraiment
que ce soit une désespérance terrible
pour en arriver à dire à un mec bon bah
toi tu vas aller prendre un avion tu vas
tuer 7000 personnes toi tu vas machin
toi tu vas faire ça c'est c'est terrible
quand même parce que j'essaye pas de les
comprendre enfin si j'essaye un peu de
les comprendre mais il y a quand même
des questions qu'il faut se poser aussi
il y a pas les méchants et les gentils
enfin les méchants c'est ceux qui tuent
quand même il faut pas
il faut se demander pourquoi ils font ça
t'imagines un peu le désespoir du mec
quand même enfin pour en arriver à tuer
d'autres gens enfin et puis en plus ce
qui est terrible c'est que en Israël il
y a un mec qui se tuait pour blesser
deux ou trois personnes maintenant ils
sont aperçus que si
7000 c'est grave quoi
que Dieu nous préserve je suis on a rien
à voir avec 6 enfin moi personnellement
et je connais beaucoup de gens n'a rien
à voir avec de non respect de la femme
de non-respects d'avoir des gens comme
ça les traiter comme des animaux tout ça
et tout ça n'a rien à voir avec l'islam
nous c'est c'est que ça ça ressemble ça
ressemble à la Torah la Bible aux
anciens testament c'est venu pour
parachever ces religions et ça parle
d'amour de tolérance de fraternité de il
y avait une cité enfin proverbe ou une
hadith comme on dit de du prophète qui
disait n'oubliez pas que entre musulmans
vous êtes des frères mais que les autres
se sont vos frères dans l'humanité donc
on est tous frères dans ce dans ce monde
il y a pas de et on est contre la guerre
contre quand tu dis une personne c'est
comme si tu es une humanité donc c'est
toutes ces choses là
c'est très important que c'est très
important que lui dise ça dans une
émission de télévision comme ça comme
l'avance parce que parce que la France
pour moi c'était essentiel c'est une
République laïque et la laïcité pour moi
c'est une valeur essentielle de notre
République parce que c'est à la fois une
protection de nos libertés individuelles
ça ne liberté de conscience de croire ou
de ne pas croire il croit quelque chose
je crois différemment mais on se
respecte ces personnes et c'est du
domaine de la sphère privée et il faut
que ça reste la semaine de la sphère
privée et donc la laïcité ça protège ses
libertés individuelles et en même temps
c'est une règle de vie en commun c'est
pas ce qu'on se respecte qu'on peut
vivre ensemble et je pense une vraie
valeur une vraie valeur République
Arditi c'est vrai qu'après l'attentat du
World Trade Center tout le monde était
très très énervé comme ça en France et
c'est normal et c'était incroyable ce
qui s'est passé et puis les jours
passants les semaines passant ont
l'impression quand même qu'aujourd'hui
les gens en France l'opinion publique en
France
commence à prendre en compte
effectivement ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire la Palestine l'Irak
etc est-ce que question simple est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une attitude
raisonnable ou une attitude municoise
honnêtement que les Français aujourd'hui
se posent des questions
qui débattent sur ces problèmes de paix
de développement d'inégalités
internationale de laïcité j'y tiens j'en
disais un août tout à l'heure et qui se
pose des questions et qui s'inquiète
devant l'éventuelle engrenage mais moi
ça me va très bien ah bon qu'on en parle
plutôt que de suivre comme ça les yeux
fermés des gens qui vous diraient faites
ci fête ça on va voilà comment non je
dis on est en démocratie c'est des
sujets très graves très sérieux plus on
en parlera plus on s'interrogera mieux
ça vaudra mais évidemment ça ne faut pas
que cette interrogation nous amène à une
résignation bien sûr quand il y a des
barbares il faut la combattre
et après il faut faire très attention et
y compris bouche a dû faire des machines
à rien parce qu'il a dit des bêtises et
il n'était pas le seul les mots ont un
sens
et les mondes non seulement un sens ont
une importance dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui il s'agit de faire justice
pas vengeance la justice oui mais pas la
vengeance il s'agit de faire justice et
pas des croisades pas des guerres de
religion pas de guerre d'une
civilisation contre une autre ça moi je
ne marche pas la justice oui parce que
c'est moins des choses qu'on punisse des
barbares pour finir j'ai l'impression
que vous ce que vous pensez là vous
dites ils sont ici sont en France ils
sont tranquilles c'est la paix et puis
l'histoire d'Israël appelle si moi je
veux qu'un État palestinien je suis pas
contre un État palestinien je pense
qu'on peut pas nous vivre dans des dans
des dans des belles maisons et eux vivre
dans des caniveaux je suis d'accord avec
ça mais le problème c'est de savoir
pourquoi ils vivent dans des caniveaux
et comment on peut aider ça si Arafat il
est milliardaire ce qui est vrai
pourquoi il est pas son peuple pourquoi
pourquoi
vraiment je je dis juste voilà ma mère
qui n'est pas juive qui est venue en
Israël qui a vu la première chose
qu'elle m'a dit elle m'a dit mais
qu'est-ce que c'est ces trucs sur les
immeubles alors je dis de quoi tu parles
et je vois qu'elle regarde les plaques
qui disent Joey
des gens dans le monde entier je dis bah
c'est des gens qui ont aidé pour faire
des écoles les universités les trucs les
machins parce qu'il y a des Juifs dans
le monde entier qui ont été généreux
mais c'est quand même la population
arabe et quand même très nombreuse s'il
donnait un franc même si ça serait
mieux d'aider les Palestine pour aider
pour l'éducation parce qu'ils ont pas
c'est vrai moi je veux dire je sais
qu'il faut résoudre ce problème et le
problème c'est dans l'éducation et il
faut qu'ils aient des écoles il faut
qu'ils aient des établissements il faut
pas qu'ils voient nous dans des dans des
bêtes dans des grands bâtiments et eux
dans dans de la merde ça je sais et
c'est on peut pas on peut pas accepter
ça en tant qu'humain ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est quand même qu'il serait à
aider les Palestiniens à aider pour
qu'ils se construisent parce qu'on sait
qu'on peut pas dîner avec des gens faire
des des désaccord promis des accords
sans que eux soient prêts donc les
établissements la police le machin on
les a formés on l'a même donné des armes
pour qu'ils puissent se défendre
maintenant ils tirent sur nous donc il y
a plein de choses qu'on sait pas pour
moi le monde il vit en deux il y a les
bons et les cons
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu